autre second débat tout de suite depuis
le mois de septembre
si vous nous suivez régulièrement vous
le savez on décortique telle ou telle
proposition de réforme avec cette
question idées neuves ou une est courte
valérie pécresse veut envoyer l'armée
dans les quartiers difficiles idée neuve
où il écourte avant d'en débattre les
détails de la proposition de la
candidate du parti l air avec jérémy
heinzmann
elle le répète désormais à chaque
meeting pour valérie pécresse la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue est une
priorité de sa campagne pour reconquérir
ces zones dans ces zones de non droit eh
bien nous engagerons des brigades coup
de poing qui rassembleront les moyens de
la police de la justice dise isc et nous
irons nous irons éradiquer les trafics
une idée que la candidate les
républicains et off avec une proposition
choc faire intervenir en partie l'armée
dans ces brigades
si on fait ces opérations coup de poing
dans un certains quartiers on aura
peut-être besoin de sécuriser la zone
par exemple ils peuvent aussi venir
aider avec le dd d'autres d'autres armes
comme le génie ou pour vous faire des
pour faire du déminage il ya des
possibilités de faire intervenir si
nécessaire et là encore si c'est
nécessaire l'armée dans son viseur les
trafiquants de drogue donc et le
démantèlement des foyers terroristes
mais du côté des militaires la
proposition ferait des sceptiques à
cause notamment d'un manque
d'entraînement et de matériel adapté
pour rappel on compte aujourd'hui en
france plus de 3000 points de deal un
trafic qui rapporte chaque année environ
3 milliards d'euros et pour lequel près
de 19 mille personnes ont été arrêtées
l'an dernier cette semaine gérald
darmanin s'est lui félicité des
résultats de la lutte anti-drogue
avançant un nombre de saisies records en
l'armée
pour faire du maintien de l'ordre dans
les cités difficiles
l'idée n'a boudé concédant que le thème
de notre débat j'accueille marc thibault
est bon soir aux assureurs et l'air du
nord frédéric ploquin bonsoir
journaliste d'investigation écrivain
auteur de l'énarque aux français brise
l'omerta c'est aux éditions albin michel
ce signal que vous aviez également
réalisé un documentaire pour la case
infrarouge vivre et mourir en citer
tournage réalisé la cité gaston gourde 1
2 de saint-denis vincent couronnement
soir vous êtes le cofondateur du site de
légal checking les surligneurs est
partenaire de vic sénat pendant cette
année présidentielle avec nos également
en duplex bellic et on qui est
historienne bonsoir spécialiste des
questions de défense vous êtes
chercheuse partenaires à 100 bonnes
universités maîtresse de conférences à
l'institut catholique de paris est
évidemment laetitia coupable est resté à
mes côtés je reprends la citation de
léry pécresse faire participer l'armée à
des opérations de sécurisation menée par
des brigades coup de poing dans des
zones de non droit de non france je
démarre toujours mais débat idées neuves
ou des cours par la question centrale
idées neuves oui des cours je pense avec
vous frédéric ploquin
passé en 20 ans de la police de
proximité est ce qu'on en voit les
parachutistes dans les banlieues je dois
avouer pour commencer c'est un grand pas
en quoi un grand bond en arrière pour
moi je vois pas je vois pas le bon en
avant que celle le côté qualitatif si
vous voulez la l'art mais bon faudrait
que faudra qu'elle nous précise
d'ailleurs 6 et c'est l'armée de terre
qu'elle veut envoyer la marine ça
m'étonnerait parce qu'en général même si
ce sont des îlots de délinquance c'est
pas dans la mer donc je vois pas jouer à
paris qu'est ce que ça peut être
l'infanterie les parachutistes avec
quels types d'armements sur le papier
moi je pense qu on est dans l'âme et bon
moi je fais pas de politique je suis
journaliste je de l'extérieur je dis
qu'on est dans la politique dans la
communication politique et que pour moi
c'est exactement comme dire on va aller
karchériser le quartier car cherrier ça
veut dire quoi enfin désole encore une
fois pour la marque car chaque album j
s'est désolidarisé qui demande qu'on
arrête d'utiliser il n'empêche ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire enlever les
taches il ya des chais pas dé dégager à
l'est et alors si de là on envoie la
sulfateuse c'est à dire l'armée en gros
je veux dire concrètement
au-delà du bon au delà de la promesse
électorale qui probablement va faire
plaisir un certain nombre de personnes
va réjouir tous ceux qui fantasment tout
d'un coup d'aller au delà de sa fin
politiquement je voudrais quand même
qu'on s'interroge sur un point c'est que
est-ce que l'armée n'est pas jusqu'à
présent l'armée française n'est pas
jusqu'à présent fait pour opérer sur des
théâtres extérieurs qu'est-ce que ça
signifierait je pose la question est-ce
que ça signifierait d'envoyer les
militaires sur un théâtre intérieur
contre donc un ennemi intérieur quel est
cet ennemi est ce que on se trompe pas
de cheval se trompe pas de vocabulaire
mais juste pour finir les pas seul tous
les ministres de l'intérieur quoique
qu'on a pu croiser depuis 20 ans nous
ont tous ont tous fini par dire qu'ils
allaient faire la guerre aux trafics de
stupéfiants et non pas combattre le
trafic de subir on va on va aller
l'excusé c'est un mot un mot de plus
dans une phraséologie globale où on veut
mettre en scène l espèce de deux guerres
un peu absurde et à l'abri vous avez
posé pas mal des enjeux de notre débat
frédéric marc philippe daubresse vous
défendez l'idée de votre candidate
j'aimerais bien que vous reprenez la
citation exacte que vous avez passé à
l'antenne tout au début seul héros
n'aurait pas tout dit elle a dit ce que
vous avez dit virgule
éventuellement éventuellement l'armée en
particulier pour sécuriser des
périmètres à l'ap a dit l'armée pour
descendre dans les quartiers à la
sulfateuse et pour nettoyer le quartier
au kärcher ce que les gens avaient dit
non mais vous voyez bien ici je suis sur
public sénat mais je suis pas cher
certains de vos confrères que je ne
citerai pas qui attend la petite phrase
en de trucs et on
voit bien le symbole ild valérie
pécresse
et je suis dans la suite de ce que vient
de dire mon mon prédécesseur et sur
lequel je suis globalement d'accord
j'étais ministre de la ville j'ai passé
plusieurs années de ma vie aux côtés de
jean louis barrault borloo à tout faire
pour essayer de redonner un espoir aux
gens qui habitent dans ces quartiers
d'accord non je ne suis pas du tout dans
une logique que martial jean leman donc
comment vous n'êtes pas dans la logique
du karcher jeune homme et je comprends
dans quel contexte le président sarkozy
enfin à l'époque et des mises
l'intérieur a expliqué en réponse à une
dame qui l'interpellait eux
qui oublie parler de la racaille on va
passer ça au karcher dans l'anglo va on
va nettoyer de la délinquance à veut pas
dire que on est dans une logique où on
est sous les pins avec les parents en
algérie on va se dire on va sauter sur
kolwezi pas du tout je connais bien
valérie pécresse j'étais ministre à côté
d'elle on a souvent parlé on a fait des
actions ensemble quand a été aux
universités en particulier j'ai relu ce
qu'elle a dit quand elle est allée chez
monsieur bourdin pour préciser la pensée
et sa pensée c'est dire non c'est pas
absolument pas systématique qu'on ferait
intervenir l'armée ça peut s'envisager
éventuellement et notamment pour des
missions uniquement normes et excusez
moi je précise les idées de sécurisation
du périmètre mais pourquoi parce que et
vous le savez très bien moi je suis élu
l'île depuis très longtemps je vais
bientôt avoir 30 ans deux parlements
donc
je peux vous citer plusieurs quartiers
de l'île de robes et vous connaissez de
tourcoing où nous ne rentrent où la
police ne rentre plus ni les
journalistes ni les journalistes où j'ai
envoyé des équipes de militants de chez
moi qui sont attendus par des jeunes qui
ont 12 ans sur des mobylettes qui le cas
échéant font intervenir des ados au
dessus d'eux qui ont 18 20 ans pour les
sécuriser et vous ne rentrez pas dans le
quartier et quand je vais voir le
directeur départemental de la police
nationale 10 messieurs le sénateur je
peux pas intervenir donc nous sommes
dans ce sujet il faut donc y faire il
faut donc faire la guerre à la drogue
oui il faut donc la faire
avec des moyens aériens
je joue dans la parole évidemment et
longuement vincent courante vous aurez
l'occasion de détailler un peu
le cadre juridique finalement d'une
intervention potentielle et sous quelle
forme de deux militaires je vais pas
vous poser la question est d honneur oui
des cours vous diriez quoi l'idée
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre peut-être
jeudi des complies 4 en oeuvre en
revanche parce que c'est juridiquement
tout à fait possible on verra dans
quelle condition plus tard mais c'est
pas une idée neuve dans le sens où notre
république s'est construite justement
sur le retrait du pouvoir politique et
civilo militaire et qu'on a confiées à
la police aux crs gendarmerie etc les
militaires traditionnellement république
n'interviennent pas sur le territoire
donc c'est pas une idée neuve dans le
sens où c'est pas une idée très
républicaine en revanche on a vu ces
dernières années des militaires
intervenir de plus en plus l'opération
sentinelles le coc vide les militaires
sont aussi intervenus nos rétines se
sont habitués à voir les acteurs
oui tout à fait l'opération héphaïstos
ça fait l'été dernier exactement donc
c'est une idée qui est neuf ans
république mais en réalité d'entrée
public du 21e siècle
heureusement ou malheureusement mais ça
c'est un autre débat est pas si mal que
ça bénédicte chéron votre votre réponse
à la question il des 9000 des cours tous
les de quoi alors c'est surtout une
image trop je pense qu'ils ne tient pas
compte de l'histoire et l'histoire qui a
été brièvement rappelé par par
l'intervenant précédent qui est qu en
fait après un long 19e siècle marqué par
des révoltes et c'est ce qui a débouché
aussi sur la grande guerre en 14 18 la
séparation entre l'action militaire qui
disent apporter un dommage à un ennemi
de la nation et l'action de sécurité
intérieure elle s'est installée dans la
dina siona et elle s'est installée pour
une raison très simple c'est qu'on s'est
rendu compte que pour qu'il y ait aucun
doute sur le fait que les militaires
servent tous les français toute la
nation quel que soit ce que font les
individus en tant qu'individu et quels
que soient les choix politiques que pose
la communauté nationale il fallait
absolument que les militaires ne soient
pas engagés dans des défenses de choix
de politique intérieure et donc y
compris dans des missions de sécurité
intérieure et en fait on voit que cette
idée là elle est à rebours de cette
longue tradition de l'histoire de france
qui s'est vraiment élaboré dans le temps
long on voit aussi qu'elle inscrit en
fait dans une tendance qui est très dans
l'air du temps que l'opération de
centimes est là effectivement instaurer
un précédent alors il y avait eu un
petit peu vigipirate avance mais la
pérennisation de l'opération sentinelles
a introduit une ambiguïté on a vu
d'ailleurs que pendant le mouvement des
gilet jaune en mars 2010neuf j'avais une
déclaration un peu ambigu à l'époque de
benjamin griveaux qui était porte-parole
du gouvernement à l'époque sur
l'implication des militaires de
sentinelle dans des dispositifs de
maintien de l'ordre donc on voit qu'il
ya cette tendance là parce qu'on est
aussi dans un moment où pour le
politique est bien affichée du kaki
affiché du militaire c'est un outil de
communication c'est un moyen d'afficher
sa puissance régalienne parce que les
images sont d'une excellente les armes
et part donc une très très bonne image
une image de très grande efficacité qu a
aussi été renforcé par leur image dans
les opérations extérieures ces dernières
années où on peut critiquer les
opérations extérieures mais les
militaires en tant que tel bénéficie
d'une très bonne image et on voit
finalement c'est une idée qui sortent un
peu sur l'air du temps comme la
pérennisation de l'opération sentinelle
est aussi un outil qu'est devenu un
outil récurrentes politique intérieure
ça peut aussi on peut aussi citer toutes
les idées d'encadrement de la jeunesse
par des militaires on voit qu'il ya des
tas de déclarations qui vont dans ce
sens là parce qu'encore une fois affiché
du militaire c'est avoir l'air efficace
et puissant dans des situations où on
apparaît globalement des bleus on va
analyser d'un peu plus près la
communication les laetitia avec vous
vous avez regardez donc la communication
de valérie pécresse depuis son entrée en
campagne selon vous elle tâtonne encore
un peu est-ce que là la reprise
finalement de kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
pour l'instant c'est sa marque de
fabrique bah écoutez j'ai envie de vous
dire oui quand on regarde tous ses
prises de paroles ses déplacements elle
était encore aujourd'hui à tour sur la
thématique de la justice pour nous
présenter ce qu'elle appelle un
programme ap unités zéro c'est à dire
une application des peines efficace
juste des jugements plus rapide une
application plus rapide des peines par
exemple un an de prison minimum pour
tous ceux qui agressent les dépositaires
de l'autorité publique c'est porter ce
sujet là puisqu'il y à des menaces des
attaques des agressions d'élus de plus
en plus fréquente donc bien sûr que
pécresse comme elle se présente à
l'élection présidentielle prend le pouls
du pays et madame a raison aujourd'hui
brandir l'armé et la sécurité est plutôt
une mesure populaire en tout cas dans
son corps à droite donc oui bien sûr la
sécurité sera la colonne vertébrale de
sa campagne elle sait aussi que c'est le
talon d'achille des manuels macron à
tort ou à raison en tout cas elle le
prend à bras le corps mais comme pour
les lois j'ai envie de vous dire qu'il y
a le programme et l'esprit du programme
et pour comprendre qu'elle sera l'esprit
du programme de valérie pécresse vous
propose de la réécouter l été sur tf1 au
jt dimanche soir et écouter ce qu'elle
dit c'est très intéressant dans la façon
dont elle a beau être justement ferme et
sévère moi vous le savez dans ma région
je la tiens d'une main ferme ferme mais
menthe et c'est ce que j'ai fait dans ma
région que je vais faire pour la france
c'est à dire une politique de sécurité
les régions n'ont aucune compétence en
matière de sécurité et pendant 5 ans je
me suis démultiplié sur ce sujet parce
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin d'un choc d'autorité dans le pays
alors ensuite elle égrène les mesures
donc on comprend la première partie de
la phrase ferme puisqu'elle dit voilà ce
que je vais faire je mettre en place à
etc mais le aimante elle ne l'expliquent
jamais je ne sais pas ce que cela veut
dire en sécurité voilà un rétablissement
de l'ordre d'être aimant pour la nation
mais elle va certainement nous
l'expliqué valérie pécresse elle a un
petit peu de mal à fendre l'armure et sa
toute son équipe le sait depuis qu'elle
est rentrée en campagne depuis même quel
hacker laquelle a convenu que vous
l'expliquer à la primaire l heure où
nous l'expliquera après mes juges elle
va l'expliquer à elle même a laissé de
fendre l'armure elle même avec les
leçons
un petit peu avec quels outils là
justement elle parle toute seule valérie
pécresse elle dit aux français je vais
vous parler directement sans filtre et
elle choisit le podcast première
diffusion hier premier épisode où elle
nous raconte ses 15 ans l'été de ses 15
ans où elle est partie dans les camps
des jeunesses communistes pourquoi parce
qu'elle avait une passion descente pour
la russie écouter vraiment quelques
secondes du début des podcasts
quand j'étais jeune à 15 ans
je suis tombée amoureuse de la
littérature russe tolstoï dostoïevski et
et j'étais très intéressé par la russie
et donc je me suis mise à apprendre le
russe en classe et pour bien le parler
il fallait aller dans le pays mais à
l'époque pour aller dans le pays il n'y
avait qu'une ce qu'un seul moyen c'était
de venir passer ses vacances dans les
camps de jeunesse communiste de l'époque
qu'est ce qu'on apprend on apprend des
choses on apprend qu'elle était
amoureuse d'omar sharif par exemple dans
le docteur jivago en interne en
honnêtement écouter ses sept minutes moi
je n'ai pas appris beaucoup de choses on
comprend qu'après la hongrie elle si bon
et celle ci d'alors contre yb la lumière
poutine a expliqué un peu son expérience
de mise mais on voit l'effort on voit en
tout cas où elle veut aller on voit
qu'elle veut finalement se dévoiler
davantage expliqué qu'ils allaient aux
français et c'est une innovation aucun
candidat à la présidentielle n'avait
jusqu'à maintenant proposer un podcast
pour se présenter marc philippe
daubresse il ya quand même cette
filiation avec nicolas sarkozy oui qui
est totalement assumée oui mais attendez
moi j'ai beaucoup de d'atomes crochus
avec valérie parce que je parle russe
j'ai passé russe première langue pour
mes concours d'ingénieurs et je suis
allé en russie comme elle parce que
quand on veut bien parler la langue il
faut y aller au même moment quel bon
oui va pas je suis un peu plus âgés pas
beaucoup qu'elle met à 14 ans j'étais
sur les barricades de mai 68 pour
réformer les programmes de l'école et
mon père était commissaire principal de
police aux renseignements généraux c'est
vous dire que bon mais tout ça pour vous
dire il c'est amusant oui mais c'est
pour vous dire que
nous je j'ai beaucoup parlé avec valérie
de tout ça c'est une femme extrêmement
sensible qui quand elle vous dit tenir
d'une main ferme je reviens au débat
tenir d'une main ferme dans les
quartiers oui il ya une filiation avec
nicolas sarkozy d'où le terme de karcher
trop c'est bon je suis d'accord avec
vous entourent communication ça fait
rappelle mais allez d'abord une fille de
jacques chirac valérie pécresse et elle
a ce côté de jacques chirac qui quelques
pas aller de manière offensive dans
certaines actions mais en même temps qui
à chaque fois montré une empathie
vis-à-vis des gens et ce qu'elle veut
dire sur les quartiers c'est que moi je
connais bien ça aussi moi j'étais en
charge de deux des huit cents quartiers
les plus défavorisés de fond j'en ai
visité une centaine à bon mais quelque
part les gens qui habitent dans ces
quartiers vous le savez bien aussi les
gens qui habitent dans ces quartiers
mais ils sont contents d'entendre qu'on
va faire la guerre à la drogue oui c'est
les premiers intime parce que sont les
premières victimes mais attendent de
l'empathie c'est à dire qu'on dit qu'on
leur dise qu'on les aime que c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont dans ces quartiers qui
doivent être montrés du doigt et qui a
des mesures à prendre qu on a essayé de
prendre d'ailleurs à un moment sous
chirac d'ailleurs justement pour les
aider valérie est en train de vous
expliquer tout ça quand faut-il essayé
d'expliquer elle a quand même pas mal de
fenêtre médiatique
certains mais bon à mon avis à ses clips
je serais content je vous aime dire si
ces chiffres sont bons ils ont été
données par le ministre de l'intérieur
dans le jdd ce week-end ils affirment
qu' à 625 points de deal en moins en
france 15% de moins et puis donne aussi
aussi les chiffres de dessaisie en 2000
21 lacets l'office anti stupéfiants qui
les donnent 96 tonnes de cannabis plus
juste pour 123 tonnes de cocaïne + 101 %
plus une tonne de d'héroïne + 24 % et
est ce que qu'est ce que vous diriez du
trafic de drogue en france est-ce qu'il
a essaimé on parlait des zones de
non-droit finalement c'est là c'est la
formulation de valérie pécresse est ce
que il ya toujours des zones de
l'endroit ou alors est-ce que le trafic
de drogue il a essaimé mais je veux
d'abord dire que le les statistiques
enfin pour moi ça elle veut pas dire
grand chose pourquoi d'abord au niveau
des saisies je dire que qu'on saisisse
100 tonnes cinquante tonnes date
strictement aucun impact sur le trafic
lui-même et pour les trafiquants en fait
les pertes liées à ces saisies elles
sont minimes dans la mesure où le
produit lui-même il faut très peu cher à
fabriquer et que vous soyez sur les
pieds de cocaïne en colombie ou de ou de
cannabis dans le rif dire c'est un
centime je veux dire c'est rien donc si
vous voulez que caen ont saisi une tonne
c'est donc temps que du moment qu à côté
vous pouvez en passer 5 c'est bon c'est
la première raison pour laquelle les
chiffres ne veulent pas dire grand chose
eauze et très bien qu'à l'époque on a
fait monter artificiellement les
chiffres de la lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants si si effectivement si
vous décidez il commissaire de police de
roubaix décide d'aller voilà à la sortie
de trois points de deal pendant
systématiquement tous les soirs pendant
trois mois va faire exploser ces
chiffres de saisies mais ça vaudra
strict
on aura juste ça c'est de la promotion
sur le nombre de points
notamment dans les villes moyennes
officiellement effectivement on est
environ
trois mille cinq 4000 points de deal en
france il faut il faut pas non plus dire
que la police ne fait rien la police
fait son boulot je pense même que la
police a pas forcément besoin enfin je
pense de ce que j'entends dire de
l'armée en renfort mais là plutôt plus
besoin de moyens elle même et je pense
que ce serait plus audible y compris
pour les habitants du quartier de leurs
moyens d'investigation de leur dire de
leur dire non pas où on va vous envoyer
leurs ailes enfin l'alarmé en
l'occurrence parce que vous êtes en
otages pris en otage par le trafic de
stupéfiants ce qui est vrai mais ils
n'ont pas forcément besoin de voir
arriver le gign ils ont plutôt besoin de
voir arriver ou de ne pas voir arriver
la police jeudi c'est à qui fera
discrètement son boulot et moi je
propose que effectivement il ya le
sicilien candidat vous ou un autre peu
importe d'ailleurs qu'il pouvait
reprendre cette idée il ya la police
judiciaire aujourd'hui elle et elle
meurt de faim de faire le métier mais
simplement ils ont perdu beaucoup de
gens ils ont là on leur met des bâtons
dans les roues régulièrement aujourd'hui
donc si le candidat qui diront voilà je
vais en faire une
obligation voilà et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et c'est pas dégeu fini
statistiques statistiquement sympathique
pour un gouvernement la police
judiciaire parce que elle va m elle peut
mettre six mois pour démonter une inter
de l'intervention parce qu'effectivement
si on dit zone de non droit la police ne
peut plus rentrer les journalistes donc
et c est ce que la perte de l'opération
d'oxymore sk quand on veut mener une
opération coup de point g policier est
ce que il pourrait pas finalement pour
être plus nombreux dans le drap sur le
point avoir démis jeu sécurisé fait en
fait ils savent très bien faire le
boulot vous regarder je remarque qu'on a
encore invoquer un vocable d'ordre
militaire qui est utilisé à marseille a
marseille la police pilotes c'est le mot
qui est utilisé en france et encore un
terme aux militaires mais en
l'occurrence il pilonne depuis des mois
et des mois les points de deal sur
marseille ils ont des résultats mais il
est pilote pas
disons à la mitraillette jourdain ils
les pilotes bernard millet puis les
pilotes pas militairement mais
policièrement au qu'ils ont les moyens
ils ont les hommes et ils vont et ils
déstabilisent honnêtement aujourd'hui
sur sur sur un an on peut dire que les
la force publique à un marseille a
repris un petit peu de terrain ils
arrêtent les dealers c'est à dire ça
veut dire qu'ils ont arrêté je suis pas
1010 leur enseignement un jeune
trafiquant mais ça suffit pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui et pourquoi le problème
aujourd'hui je finis sur lise
l'expansion c'est vrai que la
particularité du trafic de stupéfiants
sur les 20 dernières années c'est d'être
en gros partie d'un certain nombre de
lieux très répertoriés dans les centres
villes des grandes villes pour
aujourd'hui concernés la france dans
tous ses recoins les plus ruraux et
c'est là où ça devient extrêmement
compliqué pour un point pouvoir quel
qu'il soit c'est qu'en gros le trafic
aujourd'hui est incontrôlable mais c'est
pas s'est dit qu'on a perdu le combat
laissez pas embêtant mille militaires
qu'on va y arriver non on n'a pas en un
en fait le trèfle la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants c'est une
succession en fait c'est tous les jours
des batailles qu'il faut remporter c'est
pas un combat avec la guerre avec un
grand g c'est en gros c'est ce que vous
disent les policiers c'est que tous les
matins toutes les nuits tous les soirs
le policier de la bac de melun il part
au combat et il y va et je peux vous
assurer qu'ils iront pas ils vont pas la
fleur au fusil ils vont ils vont
vraiment et ils font vraiment ils aiment
leur boulot ils le font simplement il
demande il demande dans certains
secteurs très reculées et notamment dans
les zones rurales du renfort des
renforts pour arriver à faire le job est
pas forcément vous donnant l'exemple à
pied à l'elysée j'ai été maire pendant
29 ans d'une ville résidentielle est
calme dans la banlieue de lille
franchement il n'y avait pas énormément
des lacs en sol des cambriolages conclu
et puis on a eu un trafic de drogue qui
est arrivé dans un quartier sensible par
un jeune de moins de 16 ans
et on a tous toutes été repérés sauf que
le jeune en question il a été déféré
devant la justice 35 fois et jamais
condamné tu le feras plus mon petit
rappel à l'ordre et c est donc un moment
vous avez une saturation totale de la
population et le la drogue et sème
ailleurs que dans les quartiers chauds
comme marseille ou d'autres quartiers
partout et donc quand c'est aussi parce
que sarah tisseyre c'est bien sûr veille
en main et qu'il ya des clans
on s'attend à ce que
les clients
pouvoir d'achat qui font les guetteurs
sait combien de ces héros sortent un
jour un jeu en toc la baignoire
se vide plus vite qu'avant de du trafic
de drogue mais le débit il est
infiniment plus fort qu'avant et il
essaime beaucoup plus alors je reviens
je reviens au centre du débat
l'intervention de l'armée va sans
crainte je reviendrai vers vous comme
promis j'ai vu en préparant les missions
il ya des textes qui prévoit
l'intervention des militaires si les
moyens civils sont dépassées c'est la
règle des 4 i c'est ça oui tout à fait
c'est une instruction ministérielle en
fait qui date de 2017 et elle est là
pour préciser les conditions dans
lesquelles enfin les cas dans lesquels
leur zoom lens à venir sous mac rôle
exact c'est long c'est sans cesse à 14
novembre 14 et on comptait presque 14
novembre 2017 et cette instruction avait
précisé une loi enfin une disposition du
code de la défense qui dit que les
militaires n'interviennent pas dans les
domaines de sécurité intérieure sauf
s'ils sont réquisitionnés par le pouvoir
civil par le gouvernement et donc quand
est-ce qu'on peut les réquisitionner
c'est là la règle des 4 i c'est à dire
lorsque la police n'est pas disponible
il est indisponible lorsque ces moyens
sont inadaptés ou alors lorsqu'ils sont
inexistants ou encore insuffisant cc
c'est pas cumulatif a donc c'est soit
l'un soit leur tsl l'inde est issue
lundi il suffit pour faire pour pouvoir
justifier une réquisition de l'armée on
pourrait imaginer un ministre de
l'intérieur juste une réquisition de
l'armée en version de cet ex tout à fait
on peut considérer que dans les
quartiers dans certains quartiers
difficiles les moyens sont insuffisants
la police est indisponible et c est donc
c'est suffisant pour faire intervenir
qui a pas besoin pardon durée de 20 ans
il n'y a pas besoin de changer la loi
pour finalement appliqué ce que propose
valérie pécresse si je vous confirmons
pas sauf que les moyens le l'armée peut
employer dans ces cas là sont
strictement énoncé limité par exemple
ils peuvent pas aller avec des armes de
guerre tir est décalé sur le monde donc
il il ya une doctrine de l'emploi il a
très bien résumé des forces armées dans
un certain nombre de cas mais avec des
moyens très limités l'armée c'est pour
ça que valérie pécresse vous dire
sécuriser des périmètres même pas
rentrer dans les cartes et donc dans les
moyens qu'ils ont quand un militaire
intervient dans le cadre d'une mission
de police dans la sécurité intérieure il
ne peut utiliser son arme que dans les
mêmes conditions que la valise
utiliserait c'est à dire en cas d'
absolue nécessité c'est tout non
proportionnelle légitime defla dessus en
gros et puis des vents sont alors c'est
pas c'est pas la légitime défense pour
les policiers c'est vraiment dans
l'absolue nécessité c'est à dire pour
cesser faire cesser la coopération de
crimes ou un jour de choses ou éviter
qu'ils se reproduisent où
les militaires ont pas les mêmes armes
que les policiers alors voilà rectum ans
et puis autre chose aussi c'est que il y
à une disposition qu'on connaît assez
peu qu'ils aient une disposition du code
de procédure pénal l'article 73 pour nos
éditeurs s'ils veulent vérifier c'est
tout citoyen si il est témoin d'un crime
flagrant ou d'une flagrant ce qui
entraîne une peine d'emprisonnement
et bien tout citoyen a la possibilité
d'appréhender la personne et de la
déférer devant un officier ou devant les
services de police
bon ça on peut dire ce faire c'est très
très peu employée mais officielle
pauline que sont les maires il est
certes
jamais
laissé rien que a multiplié nombre de
militaires présents sur le terrain les
militaires sont évidemment bien plus
armée si vous me passez l'expression
pour faire ça et donc un militaire qui
est dans l'opération sentinelle par
exemple peut très bien appréhender ou
des personnes alors qu'il n'aura pas
forcément été mis là pour ça d'accord
bien compris les militaires justement va
écouter l'un d'entre eux et non des
moindres l'ancien chef d'état major des
armées le général françois lecointre
c'était en juillet dernier et justement
il revient sur l'armement les armes des
militaires écouter on va pouvoir
distinguer deux types de forces celles
qui sont les forces de l'ordre qui sont
chargés de faire respecter l'ordre
précisé par la loi l'ordre fixés par la
loi et ses forces de l'ordre
auront en particulier une contrainte
forte qui s'appliquera à leur action qui
est que la vie étant sacré dans nos
sociétés et dans nos civilisations
rien ne peut être placée au dessus de la
vie humaine même pas le respect de la
loi et que donc un représentant des
forces de l'ordre un policier ou un
gendarme ne peut pas tuer quelqu'un
autrement qu'en situation de légitime
défense à côté de ces forces de l'ordre
qui vont progressivement en être vous
avez les armes et quand on parle des
forces armées on parle des armées et de
la gendarmerie les armées elles ont
cette obligation en redoutable qui est
de mettre en oeuvre la force de manière
délibérée jusqu'à tuer
bénédicte chéron je reviens vers vous
effectivement sur
l'utilisation des armes et quelles armes
et comment par les militaires est
peut-être le fait que tout simplement
ils soient pas vraiment préparé à ça à
une intervention dans un dans un
environnement urbain en france
en fait c'est pour ça que cette
distinction entre ce qu'on fait en
termes de sécurité intérieure et de
maintien de l'ordre et ce conseil face à
un ennemi est vraiment très importante
parce que tout l'entraînement d'une
force militaire et c'est ce que m'ont
vraiment toute l'histoire militaire
jusqu'aux opérations les plus récentes
et diriger vers un exercice qui est
vraiment très particulier qui consiste à
porter un dommage majeur à un ennemi
alors jusqu'à effectivement tué en
maîtrisant la violence c'est à dire en
ne faisant pas n'importe quoi en
déchaînant pas une violence gratuite
mais apporter un dommage majeur est en
fait dès qu'on déploie des militaires
sur le sol national non pas pour faire
face à l'ennemi parce qu'après tout si
on était envahie et on aurait un ennemi
sur le sol national soit légitime d'y
placer les armes et enfin ça sas est
émis mais dès qu'on les déploie sur le
sol national avec l'idée qu'ils vont
être mêlés à la population pour des
tâches qui ne consistent pas qui ne sont
pas clairement ordonné à cette idée
qu'on va porter un dommage majeur à un
ennemi ça veut dire combien profondément
aller contre leur fonctionnement
ordinaire ce qui signifie aussi
d'ailleurs et c'est là que c'est
problématique quand les chefs d'état et
valérie pécresse n'est pas la seule
candidate a évoqué ce type de piste et
d'autres par le passé ont évoqué ce type
d'idées donc c'est assez partagés sur
l'échiquier politique quand les chefs
d'état font ce type d' annonce on a
l'impression qu'ils ne se rendent pas
compte non plus qu'en fait ils viennent
affaiblir l'outil militaire parce que ça
signifie qu'ils viennent placer les
armées dans une situation ambiguë qui
vient abîmer le lien que les armes et
entretiennent avec les français mais ça
signifie aussi qu'on va modifier si on
entre là si on emploie durablement et
substantiellement les armées dans des
missions qui ne sont pas les leurs qu'on
va venir modifier leur recrutement leur
fonctionnement leur manière de
s'entraîner et que le jour où on a
besoin des armées pour faire face de
manière réelle à un ennemi qui menace la
communauté nationale
cette armée ne sera plus capable de le
faire et donc c'est une position qui
al'air d'affiché de la puissance
régalienne mais qui en fait est assez
peu régaliennes dans la compréhension du
rôle des armées au service de la nation
y compris sur des choses très concrètes
a annoncé que de même si on employait
massivement les armées pour encadrer la
jeunesse par exemple où les jeunes
délinquants les décrocheurs scolaires
que sèche nicolas sarkozy avait proposé
ce à une époque en fait on modifierait
leur recrutement parce que ça
signifierait qu'on va recruter des gens
qui ne sont plus là pour s'entraîner
dans cette mission très particulière
mais pour faire autre chose on
modifierait tout leur mode de
fonctionnement mais et c'est vrai que
c'est pour ça que les chefs d'état-major
successives depuis quelques années sont
assez attentifs à 7 à cette question est
plutôt extrêmement réticent son pouvoir
parler en leur nom mais en s'appuyant
sur ces auditions parlementaires que
vous avez diffusé par exemple parce que
ils sont très conscients que c'est un
affaiblissement des armées on a vu que
ces sollicitations risque de mener à un
affaiblissement des arbres merci mes
légumes sur un mode réponse
c'est une vraie question c'est à dire
que le rsa ça sert de mettre des
militaires s'ils ont les armes pas et
sur rv au
début du débat le raisonnement tient de
qui vient d'être explorée si on ne
faisait appel de manière régulière et
dans des missions qui est d
institutionnaliser à l'armée pour aller
dans les quartiers c'est pas du tout ce
qui est envisagé on a eu deux cas dont
les histoires cadres et des opérations
de déblayage coup-de-poing encadrer et
sécuriser des périmètres c'est pas du
tout la même chose que bon on a eu deux
cas dans l'histoire récente où il a été
envisagé vous le savez bien de faire
intervenir l'armée le général de gaulle
en 1968 qui va voir massue pour
éventuellement faire intervenir l'armée
et moi je peux vous dire j'étais
ministre la ville en 2004 et 5 quant à
un moment quand il ya eu les émeutes
dans les banlieues en 2005
ça a fortement dégénéré il y a eu une
période de deux ans d'incertitude où
sarkozy est émise intérieur il a tenu
les choses mais ça aurait pu être une
intervention pour une durée limitée et
le sénat vous aurait dit ça ne peut être
que pour des circonstances
exceptionnelles et pour une durée
limitée donc vous est alors liens non
car on manque tout ça ça ne peut pas
être de manière régulière on a compris
parce que l'armée doit rester dans sa
mission à l'âge termine le service
militaire adapté aux antilles ça existe
c'est à dire que l'armée aujourd'hui
encadrent à ses attentes de jeunes qui
ont un certain nombre de problèmes pour
les pour les reformer à la vie sociétale
et leur donner une perspective vers
l'insertion et l'emploi et ça marche
très bien allez on va terminer avec
jonathan du prix yeahs qui revient parce
que
bélie chéron lalla évoqué à l'instant
c'est pas la première fois que des
politiques font ce type de proposition
tient c'était il ya près de dix ans une
sénatrice socialiste oui tout à fait
samia ghali pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent peut-être vous marc philippe
daubresse elle était à l'époque soucier
sénatrice des 15e et 16e arrondissements
de marseille classés zones de sécurité
prioritaire par le ministère de
l'intérieur et là on va faire un petit
flashback c'était vous le voyez le 30
août 2012 et donc elle s'exprime ce jour
là dans les colonnes du journal la
provence au lendemain d'un règlement de
comptes dans les quartiers nord de la
ville elle en appelle à ce moment là au
secours de l'armée dans les cités pour
vaincre le trafic de drogue une
proposition qu'elle a ensuite plusieurs
fois relancé remise au goût et au goût
du jour dans le débat public au gré des
faits divers toujours un peu la même
manière quand il ya des règlements de
compte et c'est en octobre 2017 après un
nouveau règlement de compte c'était sur
notre plateau elle en a reparlé écouter
mais bien au contraire on l'aimé bien
dans les gares on l'aimé bien partout
quand on m'expliquer mais non on n'est
pas en insurrection on est notre pays
parce que ses hommes ont adhéré comme un
état même si la réponse qu'on m'a dit
qu'on m'a donné comme a fait en
m'expliquant que le pays n'était pas en
guerre mais cela il avait déjà en train
de retard et aujourd'hui je leur dis
qu'ils ont encore une deuxième très un
deuxième wagon de retard parce que
pourquoi parce qu'ils ne sont pas en
réalité ils sont pas en phase avec la
vie que ce qui se passe sur le terrain
alors concrètement cette proposition de
samia ghali qu'est ce qu'elle est restée
lettre morte un thomas elle avait
provoqué même à l'époque une levée de
boucliers à gauche et c'est même
l'exécutif socialiste qui avait balayé
d'un revers de la main cette proposition
c'est hors de question a bétonné manuel
valls en 2012 il était ministre de
l'intérieur il avait précisé pour lui je
le cite qu'elle n'y avait pas d' ennemis
intérieurs et françois hollande
président de la république lui avait
emboîté le pas disant que l'armée
n'avait pas sa place pour contrôler les
quartiers et logiquement ici au sénat le
groupe socialiste n'avait pas non plus
rendre et y ai un pour porter quelconque
texte aux propositions de loi à ce sujet
aussi faut-il rappeler un hélas un mot
plus politique que samia ghali elle
avait des rapports assez tendues avec le
groupe socialiste ici au palais du
luxembourg et qu'elle ne s'y j'ai que
très rarement d'ailleurs au gourou elle
avait finit d'ailleurs par quitter le
parti socialiste au moment des
municipales des dernières municipales
pour un i droite ni gauche pragmatique
ce qu'elle avait dit merci à temps pour
toute ces ces précisions devraient
revenir marche ils devraient sur la l'un
des aspects de la citation de valérie
pécresse quand eddie des brigades coup
de poing dans des zones de non droit de
non france je reviens mais j'y pense
parce que et on vous parlait de
quand est-ce qu'on utilise l'armée
contre des ennemis de l'extérieur donc
là c'est quoi ces des ennemis de
l'intérieur sait plus vraiment la france
excusez-moi https rapporteur de la loi
sur le terrorisme et le renseignement à
centre y en a eu deux d'ailleurs bon il
ya bien des ennemis de l'intérieur est
d'ailleurs le procureur molas de la cour
de cassation donc c'est vrai on nous
explique que le l'essentiel du
recrutement des djihadistes qui veulent
continuer la guerre se fait dans les
prisons françaises et pas qu'avec des
personnes de confession musulmane
[Musique]
de départ c'est aussi avec un
recrutement qui se fait en milieu
carcéral d'eau tout ça pour dire il ya
bien un ennemi à l'intérieur oui mais ce
que dit valérie pécresse et des brigades
coup de poids pluridisciplinaire
pourquoi un certain nombre d'erreurs a
les doigts bien les douanes ne va
risquer et celle ci revient ce que je
vous disais ce que je lis beaucoup dans
vos livres qui sont remarquables je le
dis au passage c'est que il faut mettre
plus le paquet sur le renseignement et
d'investigation et autant on le fait on
la pose et oui à le propose on tend la
lgt oui oui bien sûr oui ça on y viendra
mais oui oui on est en train de faire
les cent premiers jours de la présidence
et il ya des mesures là dessus mais
gagner on l'a fait pour le terrorisme on
ne l'a pas fait suffisamment pour la
guerre à la drogue de mettre des moyens
accrus et de l'interconnexion de
fichiers sur les questions de la lutte
contre la drogue est donc dans les cas
restent non droit beaucoup merci à tous
avec loca j'appelle le titre de votre
livre n'est le narco français brise
l'omerta c'est aux éditions albin michel
merci à tous d'avoir six paires à ce
débat